à cet âge-là est-ce que vous vous
disputez encore ah ben heureusement
oui enfin nous direons moins vous dire
que il n'y a jamais eu d'accrro ni de
dispute ça serait mentir on s'est promis
de jamais s'endormir fâché alors on fait
un petit baiser quelquefois un peu
nerveux
mais il a été donné et le lendemain ça
repart hein la dispute est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire si on a encore des
rapports sexuels à votre âge ou est-ce
que ça remonte d' a longtemps V notre
âge il y a quand même une certain temps
mais on a des gestes très très
affectueux nous dirons que l'amour s'est
transformé en un grand une grande
affection et tendresse et tendresse et
en plus amitié voilà ça fait beaucoup de
choses qui reste et mettez des points de
suspension parce qu'on n pas tout dit